four days twenty-eight countries  millions of registered voters all across  the EU voters came out to have their say  in the 2019 European elections from a  cable-car high up in the Tatra mountains  to a sauna in this voters garden in  Estonia residents in EU capitals are  turned out to vote like here in Prague  London Helsinki and Dublin in Latvia  mobile polling stations came to voters  in rural areas  [Music]  people of different generations went to  vote even within the same family like  this one in Italy or like here in  Finland  in Berlin a retirement home was turned  into a polling station while young  Europeans from Ireland to Malta came out  in force to cast their ballots for the  first time  it's the biggest transnational vote in  the world Europeans across the Union  have used their vote and chose their  future  [Music]